chrétien juif musulman et des
personnalités politiques tous réunis le
temps d'une soirée
l'image est hautement symbolique rendu
possible grâce au dîner organisé par le
collectif des musulmans de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ses
environs pour une rupture du jeûne
inter-religieuse à un moment de partage
unique favorablement accueillie par les
représentants des différentes
confessions c'est important que l'on
puisse avoir des relations suffisamment
forte et puis que l'on se connaisse
c'est ça qui est important
on n'est pas dans la réflexion de fond
de théologie le débat de société etc
mais dans l'amitié marchent ensemble
c'est de ce tissu social et de ses
rapports entre associations musulmanes
pouvoirs publics et autres associations
cultuelles des autres cultes sur des
petits territoires qui mis bout à bout
créer une légitimité au collectif que je
préside le cam 68
pas de grands discours ni de débats
enflammés donc pour ce dîner mais la
volonté de favoriser les échanges locaux
des personnalités politiques étaient
également présentes pour ce rendez vous
inscrit dans un contexte national tendu
c'est vrai que dans cette période un peu
compliquée avec le terrorisme islamiste
eh bien il est important que nous les
responsables politiques
on montre bien que il faut séparer le
bon grain de l'ivraie
c'est bien que chacun ait exprimé les
valeurs auxquelles nous tiens
avec chacun sait leurs paroissiens le
cam 78 proposer ce rendez vous pour la
troisième année consécutive le collectif
regroupe au total treize associations
sur le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines